Kirk Cameron, as of today is when I've
seen it, has changed his tune about the
topic of hell. You know, he used to work
with Ray Comfort at Living Waters
Ministries, and they would often talk
about, "You have an immortal soul and
it's going to spend eternity somewhere.
Is it going to be heaven or hell? Which
is it, buddy?" You know, there was
always this kind of interrogation, this
threat, intimidation. Like if you don't
make a decision today, you could leave
this place, get hit by a car, and die,
and you're gonna burn forever and ever
and ever and ever. Is that what you
want? And see, I believe that God gets
zero pleasure, zero pleasure out of
fearbased conversion. God created us
because he wanted friends and he created
us with free will, which is the greatest
gift that love can give. You cannot
experience love. Love cannot be received
or experienced unless one is given
freedom of choice. The freedom to reject
that love, the freedom to rebel.
Otherwise, it's it's just, you know,
there's no other option. It's like
saying, you know, meeting somebody on a
a deserted island and she's the only one
there and she says, "You're the one for
me." I mean, there's nobody else. So,
right, there's no other options. I want
you to hear from Kurt Cameron himself.
And this is for some reason this is like
such a controversial topic to
Christians. I don't know why. I cannot
fathom why people would think this is
such a controversial topic. And me, I'm
a truth seeker. I think everyone in this
chat, I think everyone that's a
subscriber here are genuine truth
seekers. We need to set aside any
preconceived ideas and just go straight
to the word of God and believe what it
says. Not what we were taught, not what
grandma believe, not what our church
fundamental beliefs textbook tells us,
but what the word of God says in the
word of God alone. And it should not be
controversial. It's not controversial to
believe the word of God when you're a
Christian. But in this day and age,
Christians are saying, "Nope, that
doesn't sound like it lines up with what
my church believes. So therefore, it's
got to be false. I don't care what
verses you show me. I'm not going to
listen to those verses." My pastor says
this. Check out what Kirk Cameron's been
saying here.
>> Get down to it.
>> Yeah.
>> What's your opinion on this?
>> So, my position as it stands today, and
again, I'm I'm I'm we're the beauty of
this is that we're always learning and
growing, right? So, I'm open to new
light. If you guys have a position that
you can share with me, I will gladly
change my mind. I used to hold the
position of conscious eternal torment
because that's just what I was taught by
people that I love and trust. I've
learned that there are other positions
and a very robust argument can be made
for conditionalism or annihilationism as
Edward Fudge uh posits here. And it it
fits the character of God in my
understanding more than the the
conscious eternal torment position
because it brings in the mercy of God
together with the justice of God. It
doesn't leave judgment out. It is just,
but it also fits with the Old Testament
picture of the fate of the wicked, which
is to be uh destroyed. It is to die and
it is to perish, not live forever in an
eternal barbecue. And the classic verses
that used to get me into eternal
torment, you know, the punishment, uh,
everlasting punishment, everlasting
destruction, um, fits beautifully with a
destruction, punishment, judgment that
is irreversible and lasts forever. That
is the eternalness of that punishment
and that destruction. So that's where I
am today. I love Kurt Cameron's uh
mindset that he's saying, "Look, man, I
just want to know the truth. I used to
believe this because people I looked up
to taught me that and I believed their
word for it." That's all he said. He
said, "I believed it because I was
taught it. But now I'm seeing some
things." And he mentioned a guy, I can't
remember the guy's first name, but there
is a movie, if you guys haven't seen it,
it's called Hell and Mr. Fudge. It's
about a I think it was a Baptist pastor
who came to the truth of hell not being
eternal torment in hell. All right. The
Bible doesn't teach eternal torment.
Now, some of you might be getting
triggered. Oh, no. I got to click this
off. Please stick around. Please be a
honest researcher of truth and look at
all the evidence. Weigh out the evidence
before you just start shutting people
off and putting up walls. Let's come
together. Reason together. Iron sharpens
iron. Let's get in God's word and see
what the word of God says. Now, he said
something in this little interview. He
said, you know, I I used to believe in
eternal torment in hell because of
scriptures like eternal punishment. And
he said, "But that fits perfectly with
what I believe now because the
punishment, what is the wages of sin?
The Bible says the wages of sin is
death." Now, if the punishment is death
and we know that this this punishment is
eternal, that makes perfect sense,
right? You're dead. you're never coming
back. The Bible says it is appointed
unto men once to die. We're all going to
die once, but after this the judgment,
meaning we're all going to be
resurrected to judgment. So therefore,
we're all going to die, but that's not a
final death. That's not an eternal
death. The when we die for the first
time, that is not an eternal death.
Meaning, when that verse says
eternal punishment, it can't mean
anything else except an eternal death.
Because we're all going to die, but then
we're going to face another judgment,
right? We're all going to get some
reward at the judgment. Some are going
to get eternal life and some are going
to get the second death. We're going to
look at these verses. I want to show you
one more one more uh interview because
like I said, I don't understand why this
is so controversial. Like this guy says,
whoever posted this, Kurt Cameron is so
wrong about this. And I don't think he
is, but here's another guy. He kind of
has uh I'll let you hear, but the guy at
the end will talk. He's the guy that
uploaded it. So, the well-known
evangelist Kurt Cameron has just changed
his position on hell. He does not
believe that people will be eternally
and consciously in torment in the lake
of fire, but rather believes that they
will be snuffed out, annihilated, that
they will cease to exist, and that this
is more consistent with the mercy of
God. Now, I find this interesting, but
maybe for reasons that aren't readily
apparent. I recall Kirk Cameron being
incredibly popular with Way of the
Master in their methodology of
evangelizing people where they would put
very strong pressure tactics on people,
namely telling them about how horrible
hell is and getting them to want to
avoid the consequences of hell by
praying the sinner's prayer and
accepting Jesus into their heart. I
wonder if he realizes that this
theological shift of his on hell
actually significantly undermines the
very thing that urged a lot of people to
convert to Christianity. I don't know if
he's connected the dots on that, but I
want to hear from you. What do you think
about this theological shift of his, but
basically this guy was saying, look,
they used to pressure people to say, you
need to pray the sinner's pray or you're
going to burn and burn and burn forever
and ever. And he's like by by doing what
he's saying now, by saying that it's not
eternal, you know, he's actually
minimizing that threat. And I don't know
if this guy from what this guy is
saying, it sounds like he agrees that
hell is eternally eternal. And he's
saying that he's doing a disservice to
the gospel by minimizing hell. Look,
hell is is terrible. No one should want,
no one in their sane right mind wants to
be destroyed. The Bible says that God
has put eternity in our hearts. We all
long for eternity. We all want to live,
you know, unless there's something wrong
upstairs and and something, you know,
the pain of this world and the mental
anguish. And there are people that give
in to those invasive, intrusive, satanic
thoughts to end their life. And that's
that's not normal. But a normal sane
person will always strive for life. And
we want to live for forever. And people
who are dying on their deathbeds,
a lot of them are getting right with God
because they're like, I'm this I'm at
the end of this thing. So it doesn't
have anything to do with, you know, you
must teach and believe that hell is an
eternal torment or people aren't going
to get saved. I've heard people say
that. They're like, well, why would
anyone get saved? Man, that it bothers
me so bad when I hear people say, "If
hell's not eternal and real, then why
would anybody get saved?" I'm like, "Are
you kidding me? Are you insane? Why? You
know why I got saved? Because I fell in
love with my creator. The one who
breathed life into me. The one who holds
every breath that I have. That's why I
gave my heart to Christ. Because he
loves me. He created me. It had nothing
to do with if I don't do this, I'm going
to burn and burn forever and ever."
That's not love. That's saying, "Bow or
burn forever." That's not choice. That's
not love. If I put a gun to my wife's
head and I said, "Tell me you love me.
I'm going to blow your brains out." Even
if she says the words, "I love you," I'm
not receiving true love because she's
only saying it because I'm I'm
threatening her life. That's not how God
is. God's saying, "Look, I love you so
much. I created you for friendship. I'm
in love with you. Will you please accept
me so that you can receive my free gift
of eternal life? He's given us a gift.
And if we choose to reject him, we
choose to reject his gift. And his gift
is eternal life. Which means that we
don't have eternal life. We are choosing
it oursel. It has nothing to do with God
saying, "If you don't worship me, I'm
going to burn you forever." You see the
difference? One says, "Bow or burn for
ever." And the other one says, "Will you
please receive my gift of life? I want
you to live forever. He wants us to live
forever more than we want it. But the
thing is is when we choose the things of
this world, we make ourselves unfit for
eternal life. We're like a discordant
note in eternity of a place full of
perfection. There's not going to be any
liars, thieves, adulterers,
drunkards, and that's the place that I
want to live forever. And and God isn't
saying you can't come in here because
because he's some meanie. He's saying
when you partake in those things, you
cause chaos in my world. Look around us.
Why is there pain and suffering in this
world today? Because we use our freedom
of choice to do things that hurt people.
We we cheat on people. We lie. We steal.
We get drunk and do things that we
should never do. Right? Kirk Cameron
used to be in these Left Behind movies.
He used to be in movies that taught
about the pre-tribulation rapture. Okay?
I don't believe there's a single verse
in the pre-tribulation rapture. And I'd
love for you guys to check out the video
I did on it about right here. It's it's
on the live tab. And if you scroll down,
it was the third video I ever did. And
it's right here. John Rich says pre-tra
pre-trib rapture is false. Um, watch
this video. It's only 25 minutes long. I
give like every verse about the rapture.
I put it in context and prove that the
second coming is the rapture. There's no
rapture before the second coming
according to the Bible. Now, Kurt
Cameron was in these movies that's
pushing that view. But look what
happened. I asked Google, does Kurt
Cameron believe in the pre-tribulation
rapture? No. Kurt Cameron, after
starring in the Left Behind films which
depicted the pre-tribulation rapture,
has moved away from that belief, which
is amazing. Meaning Kirk Cameron is
actually keeping an open mind, studying
scriptures to see what they say. And
he's like, "Look, I I used to believe
this because I was taught this, but now
I don't because I'm reading the
scriptures and he's doing the same thing
with this topic of eternal torment and
hell." So, I think that's amazing. Now,
I'm not going to give all the answers
about hell here because I have a video
on it already. And first, I'd love for
you guys to check out on our channel
this video that says the truth about
death and afterlife, heaven, hell,
near-death experiences. This is like you
should watch this first really. And then
after that,
all your answer, all your questions will
be answered in this video right here
about hell. Your church lied to you.
Shocking truth about hell according to
the Bible. This video is going to answer
every question you could ever have about
the topic of hell. And it it just puts
it into perfect clarity. Now, I'm going
to I'm going to talk about some
scriptures. I don't have time to do the
whole thing because I want to keep this
short. But look at this. In John
5:28:29, it says, "Marvel not at this,
for the hour is coming in the in the
which all that are in the graves shall
hear his voice and shall come forth.
They that have done good unto the
resurrection of what? Life. And they
that have done evil under the
resurrection of what? Damnation. Now,
some people might see that damnation
word and they're like, "Wait a minute.
That means eternal torment." Where do
you get that idea? Damnation just means
a punishment.
Some are going to have the resurrection
of life and some are going to have the
resurrection of damnation. That's two
different things, right? Life,
damnation. All right. Daniel 12:1-2
says, "And at that time shall Michael
stand up, the great prince which
standeth for the children of thy people,
and there shall be a time of trouble
such as never was since there was a
nation, even to that same time. And at
that time, meaning in the future, when
the judgment day comes, thy people shall
be delivered, everyone that shall be
found written in the book, and many of
them which sleep in the dust, because I
believe that when you're dead, you're
dead until the resurrection and the
judgment day. Many of them that sleep in
the dust of the earth shall awake, some
to everlasting life, some to everlasting
contempt. So what do we what are we
seeing here? A contrast of we see life
everlasting
and we see everlasting contempt. Again,
a punishment that's everlasting, but the
opposite is life. So I I'm building a
case here. There's life on one hand and
there's punishment on the other. What is
the punishment? James 1:15 says, "Then
when lust has conceived, it bringeth
forth sin, and sin when it is finished,
bringeth forth eternal torment in hell."
No, bringeth forth death. The wages of
sin is death. The punishment of sin is
death.
The opposite of that is eternal life. So
if you don't have eternal life, you will
die.
John 3:16, the most famous verse on this
world. For God so loved the world that
he gave his only begotten son that
whosoever believeth in him should not
burn for eternity. No, it says should
not perish but have everlasting life.
So, we just looked at at least three
verses that say you're going to get one
thing or another. You're going to get
eternal life or you're going to get
punishment, death, perish.
It doesn't say that everyone has eternal
life, but you're going to spend that
eternal life in a good place or a bad
place. That's not what we see. So,
perish and everlasting life. Romans 6:23
says, "For the wages of sin is eternal
torment." No, is death, but the gift of
God is everlasting life through Jesus
Christ our Lord. Look, I'm sorry that I
keep saying that, you know, I'm kind of
saying it sarcastically like the wages
of sin is eternal torment, but I'm
trying to show you the vast contrast
here. You can't eternally burn if you
don't have eternal life.
Right? And the only way you can have
eternal life is if you receive the gift
of God, which is everlasting life.
1 Corinthians 15:51-55 says, "Behold, I
show you a mystery. We shall not all
sleep, but we shall all be changed in
the moment, in the twinkling of an eye,
at the last trump. For the trumpet shall
sound, and the dead shall be raised
incorruptible, and we shall be changed.
For this corruptible must put on
incorruption, and this mortal must put
on immortality. So, what's it what's it
saying here? Is it saying that everybody
is going to put on immortality? Does it
say that we are all already equipped
with imort immortality? Because that's
what we're taught, right? We're taught
it's a pagan view. But we're taught in
churches, every one of you have an
immortal soul inside of you. And when
you die, it's going to leave your body
and it's going to go to the good place
or the bad place forever. But that's not
what this says. It says when Jesus comes
at the last trumpet, the dead are going
to be raised from the dead because
they've been sleeping dead all this
time. They're going to raised from the
dust of the earth. But only the
righteous are going to put on
incorruption and put on immortality, not
the wicked. So how can they burn forever
if they don't put on immortality?
So when this corruptible shall have put
on incorruption and this mortal shall
have put on immortality, then shall be
brought to pass the saying that is
written, "Death is swallowed up in
victory. Oh death, where is I sting? Oh
grave, where is thy victory?" Only the
righteous are going to overcome the
punishment of death. It's the wicked
that are going to receive death, but
they're not going to receive
immortality. So again, we got this vast
contrast. You got some that are going to
have immortality and some that are going
to have death. Over and over, we see
this
Genesis 3:22.
And the Lord God said, behold, the man
has become as one of us to know good and
evil. And now, lest he put forth his
hand and take also of the tree of life
and eat and live forever. So when Adam
and Eve sinned, when they ate of that
fruit and they became sinners, they they
used to have right to the tree of life.
They could live forever. As long as they
ate from that tree of life, they'll
live. But what happened when they ate of
the tree of knowledge? There was an
angel set there that guarded that
guarded them from the tree of life. They
no longer can have access to that tree
of immortality, of everlasting life.
They no longer have everlasting life.
Which means what? that they are going to
die. It was 900 years later, but they
were going to die because they didn't
have access to that tree of life. What
was the reason they didn't have access
to the tree of life? Because they
sinned. So, the wages of sin is death.
When you don't have right to the tree of
life, you will die.
In Revelation 22:14 says, "Blessed are
they that do his commandments that they
may have right to the tree of life and
may enter in through the gates into the
city." So sinners don't have right to
that tree of life that makes them
immortal. It gives them everlasting
life. Who does?
Those who keep the commandments of God
in the last days who are are blessed
with the gift of everlasting life. They
are the ones that have right to the tree
of life. So I have a question for you.
This is a question to ponder. Look at
the top here. It says sin which was
eating that fruit. Sin caused being
banned from the tree of life which
caused them to die. Right? We just
talked about that. If you don't have
right if you don't have access to the
tree of life, you will die. So sin
caused separation from the very thing
that gave them life. But they that do
his commandments have right to the tree
of life. That's going to happen in the
future when Jesus comes. He's going to
give us right to the tree of life so
that we can live forever. But that's not
everybody, right? Only the righteous.
For the wages of sin is death, but the
gift of God is eternal life through
Jesus Christ our Lord. Now ask yourself,
how can the wicked burn for eternity if
they don't have the gift of eternal life
or access to the tree of life? Ask
yourself that question. The wicked, they
will not put on immortality at the last
trump. Only the righteous. The wicked
will not put on immortality. They will
not receive the gift of everlasting
life. and they will not have right to
the tree of life. Right? That's the only
thing that'll make the righteous live
forever. Putting on immortality,
receiving the gift of everlasting life,
and having access to the tree of life.
What is the opposite of that? The
opposite of that is death. You cannot
live forever in eternal torment and
flames unless you receive the gift of
everlasting life. That's the only way
you can live forever.
This is this is like basic math here,
right? Like X equals Y or whatever. If
you do not have X, then you do not have
eternal life. If you do not receive the
gift of everlasting life, you do not
live forever. Not in eternal torment. It
it can't happen. It's impossible. Psalms
37:10 and 20 says, "For yet a little
while and the wicked shall not be." This
is saying that the judgment of the
wicked is they're not going to be
anymore. They don't exist anymore. Yay,
thou shalt diligently consider his place
and it shall not be. But the wicked
shall perish and the enemies of the Lord
shall be as the fat of lambs. They shall
consume into smoke shall they consume
away.
Thank you for that thumbs down, guys. I
don't know why anybody would thumbs down
the scriptures. This is all Bible study
right here. I've done nothing but read
the Bible.
Malachi 4:1. For behold, the day cometh
that shall burn as an oven, and all the
proud, yay, and all that do wickedly
shall be stubble. The wicked are going
to be stubble. And the day that cometh
shall burn them up, sayeth the Lord of
hosts. And this right here is the key,
that it shall leave them neither root
nor branch. There's not going to be
anything left when God's judgment comes
upon them. Burned up stubble, leaving
neither root nor branch. Malachi 4:3
says, "And ye shall tread down the
wicked, for they shall be ashes
under the souls of your feet in that day
that I shall do this." What does it say?
They're not going to be neither root nor
branch. They're going to be burned up.
They're going to be stubble. They're
going to be ashes under the soles of our
feet. That is not a description of
eternal life in hell, burning and
burning and burning.
Revelation 21:8
says, "But the fearful, the unbelieving,
and the abominable, and the murderers,
and the whoreongers, and the sorcerers,
and the idolattors, and all liars shall
have their part in the lake of fire, or
in the lake, which burnth with fire and
brimstone, which is the second death."
Look guys,
there is a punishment for the wicked.
The punishment for the wicked is fire.
And it's a fire that will burn them up,
make them stubble, make them ashes.
There will be neither root nor branch.
It's going to be the second death. It's
appointed unto men once to die, but
after this the judgment. Some are going
to have eternal life. Some are going to
have the second death in the fire.
There are so many more verses. If this
was triggering in some way, if you think
I'm just making stuff up, I'm heretical
or whatever, please watch this video. Go
to our live tab, click on your church
lied to you, shocking truth about hell.
The description or the link will be in
the description.
This video is an hour and a half long.
It leaves no stone unturned. I know
you're thinking of, oh, the rich man of
Lazarus and uh it says eternal fire
somewhere, doesn't it? Doesn't it say
eternal punishment? Doesn't it say uh
all these things, right? The smoke of
their torment rises forever and ever.
All of it is addressed. Please watch
this video. Do yourself the justice of
looking into this. Be honest with
yourself. Be an honest truth seeker.
Look at all the evidence before you make
up your mind. I'm wondering if maybe
there's like one more verse I could read
on here that'll just be the nail in the
coffin for somebody.
Revelation 20:9
says that the wicked are going to come
up the breadth of the earth and the
compass the camp of the saints about
them and the beloved city and the fire
came down from God out of heaven and
devoured them.
It's 2 Peter 3:10 says that the elements
will melt with fervent heat and the
earth and all the all the works that are
therein shall be burned up. Revelation
20:13-15
says again that death and hell were cast
into the lake of fire. This is the
second death.
It's a death. Behold, I come quickly and
my reward is with me and I give every
man according to his works. For the Son
of man shall come in the glory of his
father and and with his angels,
and then he shall reward every man
according to his works.
Ask yourself this question.
If somebody's works was
sinning their whole life, they live to
be 90 years old, they sinned every day
of their life, is it just that God
should give them immortality,
throw them in a fiery pit and leave them
there to be tormented every moment of
every day for an endless amount of time.
There is a billion years and you've only
begun because there is no end to this
tunnel. you will burn forever and ever
and ever. Anyone in the sane right mind
would say that's cruel and unusual
punishment. That is a monster who would
do that. And some of a Christian will
tell you God's going to do that. Who
would want to serve a God like that? My
God is not the God that does that. I
serve the God of the Bible that says the
wages of sin is death. And I'm giving
you a gift, a gift of eternal life. Will
you please take it? Will you be my
friend? Will you serve me? Will you love
me? Will you trust me? Will you keep my
commandments? Because my commandments
are freedom and liberty.
I pray that if you've been hurt by the
church, if you've been told this satanic
lie that God is going to burn people
forever and ever and ever like some
tyrannical monster, please get rid of
that idea. Go to the scriptures alone.
Don't judge God by all those hypocrites
that tell you that God is this sadistic
monster. Please watch the other video,
The Truth About Hell. And there's a lot
of other resources out there that they
mention, hell and Mr. Fudge. If you
enjoy this video, please give a thumbs
up. It's a free and simple way to
support this ministry. If you would like
to donate to this ministry, you can do
so by going to Cash App, Vinmo, Zel,
PayPal. You can find all that. Uh you
can go to cantruth.org and we have ways
to wire us money and things like that.
We can only do this with your help. We
are a completely donationbased ministry.
You can invite us to your church and we
can speak there. You can order t-shirts
and mugs and hoodies and we get about $5
on every sale from that. But we love you
and we thank you. We cannot do this
without you.